und jetzt das heute journal
guten abend fußball ist ein spiel aus
fehlern wer die wenigsten fehler macht
gewinnt das zitat des legendären
niederländischen spielers johan cruyff
lässt sich mühelos auf politische
wahlkämpfe übertragen
manchmal ist es am besten man schaut
einfach nur still den fehlern der
anderen zu und wenn am besten auch
selbst gar nicht zu sehr drauf hauen
sondern joviale milde horche das tut dem
stolpernden gegner oder gegnerin noch
mehr weh und demoralisiert deren abwehr
diese taktische aufstellung lässt sich
im bundestagswahlkampf gerade ganz gut
beobachten die mitbewerber von annalena
baerbock können wohl ihr glück kaum
fassen dass die grünen ihren höhenflug
gerade selbst beenden
dass der spitzenmann der cdu in diesen
tagen nur ungern aus der deckung kommt
bei armin laschet auch bei seinem
heutigen auftritt anzumerken
andrä hat das beobachtet es ist ein
angenehmer termin für armin laschet
eigentlich gespräch mit der zeitschrift
brigitte plauder tun
es dauert eine halbe stunde dann soll er
sich auch zum problemfall seiner partei
äußern
hans-georg massen nach dessen angriff
auf den öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunk
weiter kein explizites machtwort den
namen von maßen spricht laschet nicht
aus und ich habe einfach nicht die
absicht jetzt zu jeder bemerken die der
im laufe der nächsten wochen markt jedes
mal dass aufzuwerten
durch eine positionierung die ich selbst
stand dagegen hat klare abgrenzung zur
afg klares bekenntnis zum öffentlich
rechtlichen rundfunk das sei die linie
der union so laschet
ein möglichst geräuschloser wahlkampf
das scheint die strategie
doch auch unionsintern werden stimmen
lauter die glauben dass es mit maßen
geräuschlos gar nicht geht ich bin der
überzeugung dass er maß nicht jetzt mal
zwei drei wochen ruhe halten wird
sondern er wirft sich regelmäßig zu wort
melden und einer der wichtigsten
wahlkämpfer für rot grün und teilweise
auch für die auf de seien die probleme
die die grüne konkurrenten gerade selbst
hat die plagiatsvorwürfe gegen annalena
baerbock lenken da nur noch bedingt ab
laschet nutzt das gespräch geschickt für
einen aufruf zu mehr sachpolitik
ich habe mir so viele gedanken gemacht
über das wahlprogramm was sind meine
schwerpunkte wie soll das
modernisierungs jahrzehnt aussehen was
sind unsere waren antwort auf den
klimawandel also darüber würde ich
lieber diskutieren als über die frage ob
da in einem buch irgendwas kopiert
worden ist oder nicht
was armin laschet noch verspricht an
diesem abend geschlechterparität in
seinem kabinett sollte er kanzler werden
beim brigitte talk ist das so etwas wie
ein homerun das niederländische
königspaar maxima und willem-alexander
sind ja gerade auf deutschland-besuch
ihnen war heute anzusehen wie sehr sie
die nachricht aus der heimat schockiert
hat eine der bekanntesten journalisten
des landes ist in amsterdam am
hellichten tag niedergeschossen worden
gtr de vries kämpft um sein leben dass
journalisten nicht nur in diktaturen
gefährdet sein können sondern auch in eu
ländern ist hier leider nicht neu man
denke an die journalisten die auf malta
in ihrem auto in die luft gesprengt
wurde
oder an den slowakischen kollegen der in
seinem eigenen haus regelrecht
hingerichtet wurde
genau wie peter de vries recherchierten
sie in den bereichen korruption und
mafia anne gellinek berichtet noch am
abend kommen menschen mit blumen zum
tatort mitten in amsterdams
ausgehviertel jeder in den niederlanden
kennt peter r de vries den fernseh
reporter der verbrecherjagd und nun
selbst zum opfer wurde mit schüssen im
kopf bricht er gestern abend hier
zusammen
in diesem krankenhaus ring der nun
schwer bewacht um sein leben er war ein
kämpfer für gerechtigkeit und dabei ging
er weiter als viele andere journalisten
dass er team peter r de vries bleibt
nicht in der rolle des berichterstatters
in einem prozess gegen den mächtigsten
drogenboss der niederlande berät er den
kronzeugen während der verhandlung waren
erst der bruder und dann der an
wald des kronzeugen ermordet worden noch
gestern abend gelingt es der polizei
zwei männer auf der flucht festzunehmen
einer könnte der schütze gewesen sein
die niederlande unter schock ein
attentat auf einen mutigen journalisten
und die pressefreiheit so
premierminister rückte die so wesentlich
ist für unsere demokratie
die kleinen niederlande haben sich zu
einem drehkreuz für drogen und
menschenschmuggel entwickelt klagt die
polizei während die mafia aufrüsten
spare der stadt niederländische politik
will für möglichst wenig geld maximale
sicherheit das funktioniert nicht
der reporter de vries ist zum symbol für
den kampf gegen das verbrechen geworden
feiert peter halte durch so die hoffnung
heute abend in den niederlanden und
jetzt erstmal die nachrichten von heinz
wolf die universität mainz hat für eine
studie über hintergründe der korona
panini mehr als 10.000 personen
untersucht und befragt auffällig war die
hohe dunkelziffer von 645 probanden die
das virus in sich tragen oder trugen
hätten gut 40 prozent ohne die studie
wohl nie davon erfahren
weitere erkenntnisse kinder sind keine
pandemie treiber und sozial schwächere
sind überproportional betroffen weshalb
sie gezieltere angebote bräuchten heute
im kabinett der neue jahresbericht zum
stand der deutschen einheit demnach ist
deutschland auf dem weg zu
gleichwertigen lebensverhältnissen weit
vorangekommen so liege die
wirtschaftskraft der ostdeutschen länder
zwar hinter der westdeutschen habe aber
weiter aufgeholt
der regierungsbeauftragte wanderwitz
sieht deutliche unterschiede bei den
politischen einstellungen der menschen
mit einer politik skeptischeren
grundeinstellung in den ostdeutschen
ländern
rund einen monat nach der landtagswahl
in sachsen anhalt und den anschließend
den sondierungsgesprächen könnten dort
nun die weichen in richtung eines
schwarz rot gelben regierungsbündnisses
gestellt werden
die landesvorsitzenden von cdu spd und
fdp kündigten auf einer gemeinsamen
pressekonferenz an
koalitionsverhandlungen anzustreben sie
brauchen dafür jeweils noch grünes licht
aus ihren parteien in haiti ist
präsident muss nach angaben der
regierung in seinem haus erschossen
worden
louis hatte das bitterarme land zuletzt
per dekret regiert unter anderem wegen
protesten gegen ihn war die 2019
geplante parlamentswahl verschoben
worden
nach der tat wurde der ausnahmezustand
im land ausgerufen
im märz wurde der welt plötzlich sehr
bewusst wie störanfällig unsere
globalisierte wirtschaft sein kann
nach der havarie eines containerschiffs
ging am suezkanal fast eine woche lang
nichts mehr
zeitweise stauten sich dort über 400
schiffe auf deren ladungen unternehmen
in aller welt warteten auch in
deutschland war zu spüren was es
bedeutet wenn lieferketten plötzlich
unterbrochen sind
schon damals war natürlich klar das wird
ein heftiges finanzielles nachspiel
haben wer kommt für die schäden auf und
in welcher höhe
monatelang wurde verhandelt erst jetzt
wurde das beschlagnahmte schiff
freigegeben und konnte heute auslaufen
davon berichtet wiegand
400 meter länge fast 20.000 container
die evergreen schiff der superlative
nimmt fahrt auf
raus aus dem suez-kanal weg richtung
mittelmeer 100 tage waren schiff und die
teure fracht aus china hier an der kette
beschlagnahmt von ägyptens behörden
rückblick am 23 märz hatte ein schwerer
sand strom wohl den frachter an land
gedrückt quer gestellt wie ein
gigantischer riegel in kurzer zeit staut
sich der verkehr an beiden seiten des
kanals jedes quadrat ein schiff am ende
warten 450 frachter auf weiterfahrt
bald eine woche ist diese lebensader
einer globalisierten welt blockiert
jeder tag kostet millionen ägypten von
der durchfahrt gebühren verlangt
kompensation über 900 millionen dollar
zuerst heute besiegeln vertreter der
japanischen räder und die suezkanal
verwaltung einen vertrag es ist nur noch
von 550 millionen dollar die rede
wir haben eine verschwiegenheitsklausel
unterzeichnet deshalb kann ich die
genaue summe nicht nennen
die 550 millionen sind eher politische
größe sagte ökonom dr muhammad ali es
dürfe nicht der eindruck entstehen als
habe sie ägypten allzu sehr unter hand
gelassen
die japanischen rede zahlen wohl weit
weniger damit etwa gewinn wieder von der
kette darf heißt es zum abschied gab's
wasserfontänen im preis inbegriffen
und jetzt die zahlen vom lotto am
mittwoch sie lauten wie immer ohne
gewähr
28 23 29 31 43 superzahl 9 und weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto punkt
zdf de und im zdf text auf seite 55 7
noch kurz die wetteraussichten morgen
ist es im nordosten freundlich sonst
gibt es gewitter mit starkregen hagel
und sturm der temperatur erreicht 20 bis
26 grad
auch an den kommenden tagen gibt es
viele kräftige schauer und gewitter am
wochenende vor allem im norden 20 bis 28
das war es auch schon von uns viel spaß
bei der zweiten halbzeit und bis morgen
viele sind
[Musik]